[Music]
so this question about the inevitability
of evolution the extent to which the
outcomes we see in the world today were
destined to occur has a number of
implications I mean just most generally
it is it tells us whether how fated
evolution was to occur how how the
outcome today was destined in a way but
it has other implications as well that
people have long speculated about and
that is what would life be like on other
planets if it is evolved would it be
like the world today here on earth or
would it be completely different and
this this question has taken on some
increased urgency or at least interest
in recent years because we now realize
that there are many planets out there
that are like earth we used to think
that earth was perhaps unique and so
perhaps life as we know it is unique
because we're the only place that it
could evolve but quite the contrary
we've now discovered that there are lots
of what are called habitable exoplanets
some people estimate millions even
billions just in our own Milky Way
galaxy so if that's the case if there
are that many earth-like planets and by
earth-like I mean about the same size
temperature atmosphere somewhat similar
running water roughly similar conditions
if there are really that many earth-like
planets many people think that it's very
likely that life has evolved on them and
so the question is what will that life
look like well there are those who argue
that because from the argument of
convergent evolution they argue that
that species facing the same conditions
here on earth evolved the same so the
same solutions by natural selection they
extrapolate to say if conditions on
other planets are similar to here then
we would see very similar life-forms
that plant that you arrive on whatever
planet you'll see animal animal and
plant like organisms that look very
familiar some people have gone so far as
to say that in fact human type organism
humanoids will occur on other planets
that there will be intelligent beings
that if we saw them they would be
recognizable which of course is what
Hollywood tells us if you watch almost
any science-fiction TV show or Moo
the intelligent life forms bipedal a
couple of arms a mouth I mean maybe they
only have three fingers and pointy ears
and they're green but they're pretty
humanoid and so some people say yes
that's actually very likely that that
humans are a very successful life-form
here on earth that we are extremely well
adapted to our environment which
ancestrally was occurring on the plains
of Africa but we adapted so exquisitely
that we now dominate the world so if
this is such a good adaptation here on
earth it would similarly be a good
adaptation on another planet and
evolution would would be likely to take
the similar course that is the argument
that is being made in some quarters now
not everyone is convinced by this
argument that evolution is deterministic
we recognize that convergent evolution
does occur more than we used to realize
but still it is argued and I agree with
this viewpoint it's not inevitable and
the reason is that there are often
multiple ways to adapt to the same
environmental circumstance and so even
though species are faced with the same
conditions they may find different ways
to adapt to them and my favorite example
of that has to do with a bird that
everyone knows the woodpecker and
everyone's heard that cat that that of a
woodpecker on a tree or on your on your
garage siding or whatever people don't
actually know what the woodpecker is
doing this is what the woodpecker is
doing it is using its beak to pound on
dead wood listening for a hollow space
the echo indicating there's a hollow
space in the wood which is where a grub
a larval beetle some other insect is
eating the dead wood and so it listens
for the sound of a hollow space when it
hears it it then starts tapping very
hard to that that that's that using its
beak as a jackhammer to dig into the to
chisel or to dig into the deep wood to
get to the tunnel once it's there the
woodpecker has an extremely long tongue
so long in fact that it wraps around its
braincase but it sticks out this long
tongue that has little prickles on it
and the tongue goes in and it snags the
the grub which looks like a mealworm or
of the people you know snags the grub
and pulls it out and eats it and that
has how that they they
capture the food that they eat well
woodpeckers are found on almost every
continent in the world they're very
successful but they don't fly very well
across water or they don't like to fly
across water and so isolated islands
tend not to have woodpeckers and in
their absence other species have evolved
to fill the same niche and the most
extreme example of a different way of
doing the same thing is a animal on the
island of Madagascar
called an aye-aye now an aye-aye is a
type of lemur now people know lemurs
from the TV show Zuma foo and maybe
they've seen them the ring-tailed lemur
are the ones they hop around very cute
and so on the aye-aye is not very cute
it's about the size maybe of a small
house cat and it's kind of demonic
looking because these big leathery ears
and these bright yellow eyes and a face
of a mother and there are the native
people Madagascar had all kinds of
taboos and and myths about them because
they look and they only come out at
night but their most extreme feature
that I think really kind of freaks
people out is that their third finger an
extremely thin looks skeletal and it can
rotate in any direction resistance
anyway they lived the same lifestyle as
a woodpecker they're looking for the
same grubs in tree in Deadwood but they
do it in a completely different way
instead of tapping with their beak they
tap with their finger they go around a
wood going tap tap tap and their big
ears are rotated forward listening for
the sound of an echo and when they hear
the echo of an empty tunnel they have
these teeth that are these teeth are
kind of sticking out like this
these chiseling incisors that are very
strong and they bite their way through
the wood and bite into the wood until
they get the tunnel and then once they
get there they then use their finger
again they stick it in there and they
snag the larvae and pull it out and so
they're doing the exactly the same thing
that the woodpecker is doing but they've
evolved a completely different set of
adaptations and so that's just one
example of how species can adapt to do
the same thing in very different ways
and we we see many examples of that in
the world conversely we also see many
examples of species that have no
evolutionary parallel what we call an
evolutionary singleton that is a species
that is very well adapted to where it
lives but no other species has done the
same thing and my favorite example of
that is the duck-billed platypus this
extraordinary animal in Australia now
people like to make fun of a platypus
but they don't realize that the platypus
is exquisitely adapted to living in the
streams in eastern Australia and so it
has very lush fur that allows it to swim
in the water that's basically almost at
freezing it has a powerful tail it's got
webbed feet for swimming and then most
extraordinarily it has this duck bill
now it's not actually it kind of looks
like a duck's bill but it's not hard
like a duck's bill it's actually
leathery
but more importantly it's covered with
thousands of little receptors and these
receptors there's two types of them one
of them can detect slight variation in
ripples of water and so if something
goes swimming by they can detect it in
the water more but in addition they have
electro receptors they can detect very
slight electrical discharges and so when
an animal moves its muscles there's a
little bit of electrical activity and
the platypus can detect
that and so when it's swimming
underwater it closes its eyes its ears
in its mouth but based on the receptors
on its bill it can find its way around
and it can locate its prey remarkable
adaptation to eating crayfish and and
other food items like that well so the
platypus lives in these streams that are
in no way remarkable there are streams
like that behind the house I grew up in
in st. Louis and they occur around the
world yet nowhere else has a duck-billed
platypus evolved why is it that it
evolved in Australia and nowhere else
well there are many examples of species
extremely well adapted but no parallel
things like the chameleons elephants
giraffes many types of plants many
evolutionary Singleton's in fact humans
are an evolutionary singleton if we are
so well adapted to our environment why
didn't something like us evolve anywhere
else in the world why didn't they evolve
on Madagascar or in South America where
monkeys colonized 40 million years ago
and so this is the counterpart to the
argument of evolutionary determinism and
and the convergence we could probably
make a list just as long of species that
have not converged and so in many cases
evolution seems not to be deterministic
that problems posed by the environment
may elicit different evolutionary
solutions
[Music]